Chris Terrio not hit finish the squares
or just asleep before this movie came
out
so that's proposed got movie came out
and some people didn't like the movie
vocal minority and so I was asked by was
any other like say maybe you can't a lot
of stuff we don't want you to do some
dad script so we did a rerun write of
the script
so the original Justice League that
Chris and I wrote we didn't even shoot I
mean there's a lot of it to be shot if
you'd actually be a hard heart idea the
scary idea we never felt because the
studio's like that's crazy
and we were so insecure at the time
after this movie came out it's gonna be
it's gonna be mass hysteria in streets
suffice it to say the truth is is that
you know that their sequence in this
movie right was always my idea that all
of that would be eventually explaining
this course it's out of surprise you
know that we would and that we would end
up in the distant future where Darkseid
has taken over earth and where Superman
has to come to the empty life and where
he and now with his ragtag band and it
was there was a few members of the
Justice League that had survived to that
world and that they were fighting to try
and you know so the Batman's would side
with the broken
half a cyborg because you know something
happened
whatever happens there they were working
on equation - Chuck flashback to tell
Bruce you know obviously I read it so
those were the things that we were
dealing with and not to say that the
studio is still you know they were still
into sort of the big book of the details
of how and why everyone was mad at each
other or what that was the stuff whether
they were a little bit like because you
know Louis you know when it's in the
little teaser where the Justice League
teaser it wasn't in the movie apparently
where I guess we're where Wonder Woman
says is this line where Bruce says I was
right here and Barry Allen came to me
and he said Lois Lane is cute right and
then she goes he is the Superman every
herd has one and he goes I think of
something more darker right and so and
so and what it means is that the thing
that was darker was that you know it was
all about if Lois died Superman would
succumb to the anti-life forest right
and if Superman knew there somehow
it was Bruce's responsibility to protect
Lois he would have been mad at him in
this movie right like so that's why I
he's that's why he says she is my world
and he took that's kind of that was sort
of that and then of course he has to
jump back and the other thing that we
were working on was this idea that
cyborg widths or sidewalks said to Bruce
in the distant future like there's two
windows we that come up with this
time-traveling concept where basically
the way the window the tiling window
work is that it's not awesome physics
doesn't make any sense but that you had
you had to jump you have to do a time
job
when the earth was in a relatively the
same spot right because if you did a
time jump and the earth wasn't like in
the same position in space you would
jump into space and just be like dead
and so okay so so there's always like so
we'll give two windows right to do the
jump and southward stairs like what what
you know which of these two windows do
you think we should use and Bruce was
like well what window would you put me
through you didn't ask
and he's like this one and then he's
like use the other one Barry Allen
wasn't much picking back to you yelling
at me about like nonsense because he had
to jump right before dark side boob tube
to the Batcave to murder Lois so you
so that was the way hi everyone its
charlie zack snyder recently did that
special QA and screening of a couple of
his movies and talked about alternate
scenes the original cut of justice lee
what that was gonna look like what the
sequels were going to be him paying off
moments from Batman V Superman like the
nightmare scene in an alternate
post-credit scene where he talks about
what's happening with Lois Lane when the
flash comes back to visit him but some
of the scenes that he describes are so
hardcore so if you're new to the channel
I do DC videos like this every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
this is nuts and all those alternate
scenes weren't the only part of this -
he also talks about some original ideas
they had about the Martha scene from
Batman V Superman that sound even
crazier than the scene that they
actually had in the movie so we started
off talking about the nightmare scene
from Batman V Superman we all had a lot
of ideas about it when it first came out
like is this a nightmare or is this an
actual vision of something that's going
to come to pass and will there be some
sort of flashpoint moment during this
universe the reason why Superman is so
pissed off here why you have the sons of
Superman which is sort of a version of
the sons of Batman from the Frank Miller
Dark Knight Returns comic book is that
he's succumbed to the anti-life equation
because Lois Lane has died and he blames
Batman for her death so in the distant
future when they're actually paying this
moment off in one of the future Justice
League sequels in this post-apocalyptic
world where Darkseid has taken over the
earth a very broken cyborg is working
with this version of Batman the
nightmare Batman that you see in this
scene and they're trying to come up with
the solution to send flash back in time
so that they can warn younger Batman and
pay off this scene with flash coming
into the Batcave saying Lois Lane is the
key explaining what he needs to do so
you get to the end of Batman V Superman
Superman still dies in the original
version there was supposed to be an
alternate post-credit scene where he's
talking to Wonder Woman which would be a
bit of a Justice League teaser where he
explains the vision that he got of the
flash and what he thinks that it means
so he says I was right there Barry Allen
came to me and said Lois Lane was the
key
Wonder Woman says to him she is to
Superman every heart has a key and then
Batman goes I think it's something more
something darker then they have their
Empire Strikes Back downer ending where
things go badly setting off the
nightmare timeline so Darkseid
knowing the Superman is the key to
conquering earth boom tubes into the
Batcave kills Lois Lane where Batman is
trying to protect her that sets off this
timeline where everything goes to
so you proceed into that timeline in
future Justice League sequels then once
we get to that moment in the future
where they're all sitting together
trying to find a way to go back in time
cyborg and flash are trying to come up
with this really complex time-travel
equation but because it has to be so
precise there are only two moments in
Batman's history that they can send him
back to so the brief joke is that he
explains during that clip is the cyborg
ask Batman which of the two moments that
he should send flashback to in Batman
asked him which one would you send him
back to if you did not ask for my input
so cyborg tells them that man goes great
send in to the other one because clearly
you sent him to that first one the
original time it didn't work out so we
should try that other moment so they
send him back it works that time that's
how they wind up fixing the earth with a
very reverse flashpoint style twist so
you can kind of see we're in the middle
of Avengers infinity war and Avengers
end game and this implied that they're
actually using a lot of those same
twists to fix the universe because they
know snapped everyone so not only a Zack
Snyder saying that their original idea
the dark idea that scared the studio
which was Darkseid killing Lois Lane
sort of altered their trajectory and
then obviously things went down the way
that they did and they changed the movie
even more so the original cut that
people have been asking for this Zack
Snyder cut never actually got filmed
because they finished the script like
the original version right as Batman V
Superman was hitting theaters so they
were already super far along in the
process which is why it was harder for
them to change the movie even more had
they been given more time it probably
wouldn't have turned out quite the way
it did but this just presents a much
darker idea for the DC Universe I did a
separate video where we found out a
little bit more about Green Lantern's
involvement in those future Justice
League sequels I'll link that video at
the end of this because that's sort of
the companion piece to this where Zack
Snyder is really only talking about a
couple key twists that we didn't know
about before the other video explains
what each of those other future Justice
League sequels would have been that got
us to that future timeline where they
fix everything
the other thing that he explained during
this panel too and I'm really happy that
they did not do is his Wendy talks about
the Martha moment from Batman V Superman
the other idea that they thankfully did
not film is the idea that both
their mothers the martha's would
actually be the same Martha and they
would actually the same a mother which
just sounds ridiculous if you know
anything about the comic book Canon that
means the Batman's mother would have let
him think that he was growing up an
orphan with both of his parents having
died in Crime Alley and not telling him
this whole time his entire life it would
have been absolutely ridiculous so
everybody just post your reactions to
these alternate scenes in the comments
below like are you happy that they
didn't film this stuff or would you have
actually rather seen Darkseid kill Lois
Lane and I feel like there isn't a
really great answer to that question but
in related Marvel news they just
released a whole bunch of new Avengers
and game promos revealing exactly who
lived and who died after the snap so
I'll do a video for that later today it
should be up in a couple hours
so while you wait for that click here to
learn about the story of the cancelled
Justice League trilogy all those other
scenes that they wound up not filming
and click here for my brand new
spider-man far from home promo breakdown
in Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight